Hello, everyone, and welcome
to lecture 8 of CME 295.
So today's topic will
be LLM evaluation.
And I think this
class is probably
one of the most important
classes of this quarter
because the idea
is if we don't how
to measure the
performance of our LLM,
we don't really know
what to improve.
And so this class
will focus on how
we can quantify how
the LLM performs
in a bunch of different cases.
So with that said,
we are going to start
the class as usual by recapping
what we saw last week.
So if you remember,
last week, we
saw how our LLM could
interact with systems that
are outside of the LLM itself.
So we saw one core
technique that
is called RAG that allows
our LLM to fetch information
from external knowledge bases.
And so here RAG stands for
Retrieval-Augmented Generation.
And we saw how we could
improve the retrieval system.
So we saw that it was
composed of two main steps.
So one was candidate
retrieval, which
is typically something that is
done with a bi-encoder setup.
So Sentence-BERT
was a good example
of how people would
design such a model.
And so this first step
is typically there
to filter down the potential
relevant candidates for a given
incoming query.
And then we saw that there
was a second step, which
was reranking, and that one was
a bit more involved and involved
cross-encoders, which
were more sophisticated.
And we also saw some ways to
quantify how well our retrieval
system performed.
And then we also
saw something that
was called tool
calling, which is
the ability for a
model to which tool
to call with which argument.
So if you remember,
if we give our LLM
the knowledge of the tools
that are available to it,
it can figure out
which arguments
it needs to input to the
function as a function
of the input query, and then
run that function and then
output the result in natural
language to the user.
And then we also saw how agentic
workflows were composed of.
So spoiler alert,
it's something that
is a combination of the
two previous methods, so
RAG and tool calling.
And in particular,
given an input,
we're allowing our model
to make multiple calls
to call different tools
to fetch relevant data
from other knowledge bases.
And we saw one example
that was successful
from the current
applications, which
was AI-assisted coding, which
relies on this principle.
And React is typically the
framework that people would use.
So reason plus act, which is
decomposing this into observe,
plan, and act steps.
Cool.
So this is what
we saw last time,
and we also so started
from this slide last time.
If you remember, our LLM has
strengths but also weaknesses
that we're trying to mitigate.
So in particular, the
focus of lectures 6 and 7
were on methods to improve
reasoning of the model and ways
for the model to fetch
knowledge from other systems,
as well as performing actions.
And today, we're going to
focus on the evaluation part,
in particular, given a response
that the model is giving,
how can we quantify how well
the LLM is giving its response?
Cool.
So first of all, I would like
to define the term "evaluation"
and the meaning that we
will use for this lecture.
So when we say, I want
to evaluate my LLM,
it can actually take a
lot of different meanings.
So when you say, let's
evaluate the LLM,
it can mean let's evaluate
the performance, the output.
Let's evaluate this based
on coherence, factuality.
Let's evaluate it based
on latency, so more
system-related
metrics or pricing
or how often it is up and so on.
So just to make sure
we're on the same page,
this lecture will mostly focus
on the output quality part.
And in particular, we'll
focus on quantifying how
good the actual response is.
And here you will note that
this is a challenging problem
because as we saw
previously, our LLM is
a text-to-text model that can
output basically anything.
So it can be natural
language, it can be code,
it can be math reasoning,
and so on and so forth.
So it's very hard to come
up with universal metrics
to evaluate that.
So we will see how people
do this in practice.
Cool.
So given the fact that our LLM
generates free-form output,
one could imagine that
the ideal scenario for us
to evaluate the LLM output
would be to every time
ask a human to
rate the response.
So here the ideal
scenario would be,
OK, I give a prompt to my LLM.
It gives a response.
I ask a human to rate it,
and I start again and again.
And what I do is at
the end of the day,
I just collect all
these human responses,
and I try to quantify the
overall performance of my model.
Well, as you can
imagine, the main problem
is that such a system would
be very cost-intensive.
But let's look at
this into more detail.
So if you remember, the LLM
outputs are really free-form.
And there may be cases that even
human judgments may be something
that is fuzzy because maybe
the rating task in itself
is subjective.
So let's take the
following example.
Let's suppose I ask my LLM what
birthday gift should I get.
And let's suppose the LLM
responds with a teddy bear is
almost always a sweet gift.
Just pick one that
feels right for you.
So let's suppose
I want to evaluate
this response with respect
to the usefulness dimension.
I may have one human
reader that says, yeah,
it's pretty useful because teddy
bear is pretty indicative of,
I guess, what the user
should get as a gift.
But then another reader
may say, no, actually,
it's not useful because maybe
the response didn't specify
exactly which teddy bear.
Should I have a bear?
Should I have an
elephant, a giraffe?
Which stuffed
animal should I get?
So there is this notion of
inter-rater agreement, where
we're basically concerned
with making sure that everyone
is aligned on how to rate those
responses because sometimes
like in this
illustrative example,
it's maybe a little
bit subjective.
So responses may vary.
So what people want
to do is to make sure
that the guidelines are clear
enough for everyone to rate
these responses in
a consistent manner.
So people come up with
agreement types of metrics.
So a very natural metric that
you may think of is the quote,
unquote, "agreement rate."
So for instance, you
have these two raters.
So what you do is
you just measure
the proportion of
the time that the two
raters give the same response.
And let's suppose the
response here is binary,
so let's say, yes,
good or not good.
Well, do you see a problem
with such a metric?
Is this a good metric?
I guess another way to
ask this question is,
if I give you a given
number of agreement rates,
can you tell me if it's a good
number or if it's a bad number?
Well, let's take the example
of, let's say, two raters,
let's say, Alice
and let's say, Bob.
And let's suppose we have two
different types of ratings
that these raters can give.
So either, let's say, yes, it's
good, so 1, the output is good,
or the output is not good.
So if we assume that
the first rater gives,
let's say, random responses
with some probability P of A
for being good and 1 minus
P of A for being not good.
And then, let's say, Bob, who
should have eyes and a smile,
has a P of B for being
good and 1 minus P
of B for being not good.
Then let's compute the
agreement rate for this case.
So the agreement rate is
basically the probability
that rater A and rater B agree.
And so here A and B agree
if A and B both vote 1
or when A and B both vote 0.
But if they give their response
in an independent and random
way, well, if you use this
probability concepts that you
know, then we will have
probability of A and B
responding to 1, which is
probability of A responding to 1
times probability of B
responding to 1, and same for 0.
So we will have
something like this.
So P of A, P of B
plus 1 minus P of A,
1 minus P of B. So this
one is A and B say 1
And here A and B say 0.
So let's see what the agreement
rate would be in that case.
So if we assume that suppose
that-- let's suppose,
P of A is equal to P of B, which
is equal to, let's say, 0.5,
then the agreement
rate would be--
so agreement rate would be--
so I'm just replacing
the numbers here,
so 0.5 squared plus 0.5 squared.
So it's 0.25 plus 0.25,
which is equal to 0.5.
So what that means is if
we're just letting our raters
rate these things in a random
way with some probability
P of A, P of B, we would already
have an agreement rate of 50%,
just by pure random chance.
And so one thing
that I want to say
is, that this agreement
rates, by pure chance,
is a function of the probability
that each of these raters
give these ratings.
And so if this probability
is actually higher,
the agreement rates by
pure chance is also higher.
So what that means?
So what do I want to say?
I want to say that if we just
take the agreement rates,
then it's very hard
to put it into context
in terms of what you would have
gotten if things would have
happened just by pure chance.
So for this reason,
people have come up
with a series of metrics that
try to make it more relative
to this baseline, which is, what
would happen if our raters would
choose things randomly?
And so you have these
metrics-- like for instance,
this one is the
Cohen's kappa metric,
which computes a quantity that
is a function of this agreement
rate by chance, and
take the observed one,
such that if our observed
agreement rate is greater than
the "by chance" agreement
rate, then our coefficient is
positive.
So when it's
positive, at least you
know it's going in
the right direction.
So here, if the observed
agreement rate is equal to 1,
then kappa is equal to 1.
But if our observed agreement
rate is below the "by pure
random chance" agreement rate
that we saw on the blackboard,
then our coefficient
would be negative.
So long story short,
there is a bunch
of metrics that try to
quantify inter-rater agreement
rates using these
kinds of formulas
to be able to make these
quantities relative to what
would happen if things
were done in a random way.
And so that's why you may see
a bunch of metrics out there.
So here is Cohen's kappa
that people use for cases
where there are two
raters, but then
you have extensions,
such as Fleiss's kappa
and Krippendorff's alpha
that you may see out there.
So they all rely on
this idea that we
should have some baseline,
which is our raters just
randomly picking
answers, and try
to see how much better our
actual agreement is compared
to this.
So does that make sense?
So I guess what I want to say
is that the first limitation
of asking humans to
rate our LLM outputs,
which was sometimes the
task being subjective,
can be something
that we can quantify
with this inter-rater
agreement metrics.
So what people
would typically do
is they keep track of how
good that agreement is.
And if, let's say, we
have a quantity that's not
satisfactory, people would
just hold some quote, unquote,
"agreement sessions" between the
raters to just align on how they
should rate the answers so that
it can be seen as just a health
metric to track how
consistent your ratings are.
And this is typically something
that people use in practice.
So up until now, we've seen one
limitation of human ratings.
Well, second limitation, I
think I also said it previously.
It's really slow.
If you ask someone to rate
a thousand LLM outputs,
well, it will take them a while.
And it's, of course, expensive.
So all of that to say that
our ideal scenario of asking
a human to rate every
LLM output is not
something that is practical.
But we can leverage
human ratings in some way
because we've seen that even
if the task is subjective,
we can have a way
to align our raters.
So now let's move on to
another way to go about doing
this, which is by using
some rule-based metrics.
So here I'm just going
to revise the setting
that I mentioned before.
And instead of asking our
humans to write every LLM
output, this time,
I'm just going
to ask them to write the
references or the ideal outputs
for a given set of prompts,
just fix that for good,
and then use some kind of metric
that would compare the LLM
outputs with those references.
So here the main difference
is, let's suppose I have
a given set of prompts fixed.
Well, I can make
iterations in my model
and always compare
the outputs of my LLM
with this fixed reference,
instead of always asking humans
to rate that again and again.
So it's already an improvement.
And we will see
a little bit what
are the kinds of
rule-based metrics
that you will see out there.
So ideally, these
metrics should reflect
the performance of the LLM
output in an optimal way.
And what I mean
by an optimal way,
it is to make it be a
little bit flexible,
given the fact that natural
language is not always something
that you can say
in one given way.
So for instance, when I provide
a response to a given prompt,
there can be very
well a case where
I can formulate the response
slightly differently,
but it will still
be just as good.
So the idea behind
this matrix is
to make this comparison
a little bit flexible.
So let's start
with one common one
that people use in
the translation case.
So this metric is
called METEOR, and it
stands for metric for
evaluation of translation
with explicit ordering.
So the idea here is to compare
reference and predicted,
and we'll see how
it's being done,
and also penalize cases
when words are not
in the same order, which is
explaining why the metric is
called with explicit ordering.
So the formula is as follows.
So it is some F score
times 1 minus some penalty.
So the F score here is--
you may be familiar
with F1 score.
So it's like the harmonic
mean with equal weights.
So this one is with
the variable weights.
So it is a function of
precision and recall,
where precision is the
proportion of the unigrams that
are in your predicted
sequence that are
matching with the reference.
And the recall is the
proportion of the unigrams
in the reference
that are matching
with what is in the predicted.
So it's basically matching the
usual precision recall metrics
that you know.
And then we have
another quantity here,
which is the penalty.
And I mentioned the
penalty here tries
to incentivize good ordering.
So if it's ordered the
same in the reference
and in the prediction,
then it's good.
Otherwise, it's bad.
And so here there's a
bunch of quantities.
So gamma and beta are
hyperparameters that people
arbitrarily choose.
And it's a function of C, the
number of contiguous chunks
that are matched over the
number of matched unigrams.
So ideally, you would want C
that would be as low as possible
because if you have a low
number of contiguous matches,
it means that your contiguous
sequences are long,
which means that the
ordering is the same.
So you want C to be low and then
matched unigrams to be high.
So you want that penalty
term to be low for a good--
I guess, for a prediction
that has the same ordering
as the reference.
So I guess higher METEOR score
means better translation,
according to this
way of doing things.
So I guess when you
look at this formula--
first of all, it
looks very arbitrary.
I have alpha as a
hyperparameter, gamma, beta.
So it's kind a recipe, I feel.
So that's one.
And the second thing
is that it does not
allow for stylistic variations
because here we're measuring
the number of matched unigrams.
Although the metric
expands the range
of what it's called matched
unigrams by taking into account
things like words that are
synonyms of one another
and things that are of
the same roots, but still,
it is not extremely
satisfactory in that sense.
So METEOR is one such metric.
You have another one
that's being used
or that has been used in
translation tasks, which
is called BLEU,
which you may know.
So BLEU stands for bilingual
evaluation understudy.
And you can think of this as a
precision-focused kind of metric
that looks at the number
of matching n-grams
over the n-grams that are in the
prediction, which is why it's
a precision kind of metric.
And it also has a penalty term.
Here it's called brevity
penalty because given
that it's more of a
precision kind of metric,
if you translate something
that's very short,
you may be able to
gain the metric.
So you want to penalize the
translation being too short.
So we're not go going
to a lot of details,
but I just want to just show
you the kinds of metrics
that are out there.
So METEOR is one,
BLEU is another one.
And ROUGE, which
you may have heard,
is also another one, typically
used for summarization tasks.
Again, same idea,
and it has a bunch
of variants that you
may see out there.
But long story short, all
these metrics, they all
compare the output
with a reference.
So as we saw, one key
limitation is that they do not
allow stylistic variation.
So let's take an example.
So let's suppose I
say, a plush teddy bear
can comfort a child
during bedtime.
Well, the exact same
thing, you can say it--
I can say it in a
really different way.
So soft stuffed
bears often help kids
feel safe as they fall
asleep, or many youngsters
rest more easily at night
when they cuddle a gentle toy
companion.
So in all these cases,
the metrics that we saw
would really
perform very poorly.
So that's one key limitation.
So the second key limitation is
correlation is not that great.
I mean, you can imagine
that people have come up
with all these
hyperparameters to make
it be correlated
to human ratings,
but they're not that correlated.
And the bottom line is, it still
requires human ratings to just
get started.
And sometimes you
just can't afford
to have human ratings,
maybe in your project.
So I guess there are still
some key limitations, which
is the reason why--
all of that to say, I want to
motivate the key methods of this
class or of this lecture,
which is called LLM-as-a-Judge.
We spent the first
seven lectures
motivating these large language
models that are pretrained
on huge amounts of data
that are tuned in a way
to match human preference.
So they do contain
human knowledge.
They do contain some indication
of what humans may prefer.
So the idea here is to have
our model response be actually
an input of yet another LLM.
And that LLM is something
that people typically call
LLM-as-a-Judge.
So it was a term that
was introduced in a paper
from two years ago.
So here the idea is to use
an LLM for rating purposes.
And things that you
would see as input
would be the prompt
that was used
to produce the response, the
response, and the criteria
along which you want
to grade your response.
And so here LLM-as-a-Judge would
give you the following outputs.
So the first thing is it
would give you a score.
So here you can think of
it as a binary scale score,
so pass or fail, and
this is very new, also
a rationale because LLMs,
they understand text.
So they can also explain you
why they graded something
with a given score.
And that part is
the key difference
with previous methods.
We are able to explain why
the metric or the model
is giving us a given score.
And this is quite good
because in the other,
let's say, rule-based
world where
you would have all these
formulas and multiplication
and all these things,
and sometimes you
would come up with a
number that would not
be very self-explanatory.
And this is luckily something
that LLM-as-a-Judge addresses.
So to recap, what we want
is to use an LLM as a way
to grade the response.
So here you would have typically
the following kind of prompts.
So you would state,
OK, I want to evaluate
my response with respect
to a given criteria.
And then you give
the prompt that you
used to generate that response
along with the model response.
And then you would ask
the judge to return
two things, the rationale
and then the score.
So one little trick
I want to point out
is people typically ask
the model to first output
the rationale and
then the score.
And the reason why we
typically do that is it's
something that
empirically improves
the quality of the results.
But then given what
we saw, I think in,
lecture 6, if you remember
the reasoning class,
we saw that these
reasoning models that
are being trendy, especially
in 2025, what they do
is they first output
a chain of thought
before giving the answer.
So you can actually think of
this trick as being on the same
idea of reasoning models,
as in, it allows the model
to externalize, verbalize
its quote, unquote,
"thought process"
before giving the score.
So it gives it a chance to
really figure out what is good
or what is wrong in
the model response.
So far, so good?
Any questions on,
I guess, the setup?
All good.
So now I have a
question for you.
If I give the following
prompts to my LLM-as-a-Judge,
am I guaranteed to have a
rationale and a score that I can
parse?
Am I guaranteed?
No?
Yeah, exactly, no.
The answer is no.
You're not guaranteed to
have a rationale and a score
that you can parse
because this model has
some probabilistic nature to
it with the sampling process.
And it's not something that
you can really control.
So I guess my follow-up
question is, do you
know a technique
that would, I guess,
guarantee you to have
a structured response?
So hint is a technique that
we saw towards the beginning
of the class.
I'll give you a little hint.
So if you remember on
slide 65 of lecture 3,
we saw a technique called
constraints-guided decoding.
So if you remember, the
idea here is to constrain
the decoding thought process
by allowing our model to only
sample from quote,
unquote, "valid" tokens.
And we typically
do that in cases
where we want our output
to have a given format, so
let's suppose, a JSON format.
And we want absolutely
that format.
So what people do is
they use this technique
to guarantee the
form of the response.
And in case you're
using this provider,
like the providers that are out
there, like for instance, OpenAI
or Gemini or Anthropic,
this technique
is known under the
name structured output.
So in your projects, if you
want to constrain the decoding
process in order to output the
response of a given format,
so let's suppose my
format is a response,
and I cannot represent
it by a class,
and there are two attributes,
so rationale and score.
Well, typically,
you can reference
that with the
argument text format
equal to that representation.
So this, I believe, is
something that OpenAI does.
I'm not exactly sure if it's
exactly the argument name
that you would see for
the other providers,
but they're all, I guess,
along the same lines.
Does it sound good?
So the key word here
is structured output.
Whenever you want a
response of a given format,
you would just go for that.
Cool.
So just to recap, our
LLM-as-a-Judge has two main
benefits.
So the first one is that we
do not need a reference text.
We do not need human
ratings to just
get started because our LLM
already has a lot of, I guess,
knowledge that it has acquired
during pretraining and human
preferences and so on.
So you do not need that.
And then the second
thing is you can
interpret the score
with the rationale
that it is being output.
And that is also
quite remarkable.
So just as an example,
here you would say,
evaluate the quality
of this response.
So you would have
some rationale that
would explain what
this response has
or doesn't have that
makes it good or bad
along with the score.
Cool.
And I believe-- now we're
going to see the kinds
of LLM-as-a-Judge that
you can see out there.
Of course, there
are many variations,
but there are generally two
types of LLM-as-a-Judge that you
will see.
So the first one is you have a
single output, a single response
that you want to evaluate.
And here you would ask
LLM-as-a-Judge to say, OK,
is it good, or is it not good?
And the second big kind of
LLM-as-a-Judge that you will see
out there is pairwise
kind of setup.
So you have two responses, and
you say, is response A better,
or is response B better?
And here you would
obtain a response
either that one or this one.
So if you remember, we have
seen in previous lectures
that there are a lot of
situations where we would want
to have preference data, for
instance, in the preference
tuning class that we had,
I believe it was lecture 5.
So these kind of
methods can also
be a good way to synthetically
generate preference ratings
where you have two responses.
And then you ask your LLM to
say, OK, I prefer that one.
And you can use that
one as the label
to train your reward model.
Does it sound good?
Any questions on the
setup or everything
that we've talked about so far?
Cool.
Everyone is on the same page.
So now let's see what can go
wrong with our LLM-as-a-Judge.
So let's think of the
possible kinds of failures
that we can encounter.
So the first one is
called position bias.
And as the name
suggests, it has to do
with the ordering
at which we present
the responses to our model.
So let's say, if
we ask our model,
is response A better
or response B?
Well, there is a chance that the
model responds with response A
just because it was the
first one to be mentioned.
So that bias is
called position bias.
So it's where the position at
which you place the response
matters in the judgment of
the LLM-as-a-Judge model.
And I guess, as a way
to remedy that, people
have different techniques.
But one typical technique
would be to ask the model,
is A or B better?
And then ask the model,
is B or A better?
And then take the
majority voting.
So if both of them lead to the
same response, then it's good.
But if the response changes,
then it may not be good.
So you may want to
do something else.
There are a bunch
of other techniques.
So I know there's
a bunch of papers
that try to tweak the
position embeddings,
but those ones are
a bit more advanced.
So it's not typically
the thing that you
would do just out of the box.
So taking the average
or taking the majority
voting of this position swapping
is typically what you would do.
Cool.
So this was the
first kind of bias.
The second bias is
called verbosity bias.
So let's suppose you
have two responses.
And the first response
is short and concise.
The second response
is something that
goes much more into
details, is typically
something that is more verbose.
Well, there are cases where the
model will tend to, I guess,
prefer responses that are
just more verbose just
because they're more verbose,
not necessarily because they're
more correct.
And for that, it's maybe
a little bit trickier.
So people typically try
to explicit this dimension
in the guidelines.
When they input, I guess, this
question to the LLM-as-a-Judge,
they say, well, make sure to
not pay too much attention
to the length of these
responses to not, I guess,
prefer something just
because it's more verbose.
So that's one kind of method
that you will see out there.
The second one is
to just also add
some examples, in-context
learning examples,
to the model to just,
I guess, tell it to,
I guess, show by example
that verbosity is not
something you should prefer.
And then the last one is to
have some kind of penalty
on the output length.
So you can ask your
model in a pointwise way,
how good is 1, how good is 2.
And then try to penalize
that with the length.
So that's something that
also people may use.
So we've seen position bias.
We've seen verbosity bias.
Now we will see the
third kind of bias
that you may see
out there, which is
called self-enhancement bias.
And so that one has
to do with the fact
that if you ask a model to judge
an output that was produced
by itself, well,
the model will tend
to prefer responses that are
generated by itself, regardless
of whether or not the
other one was more
aligned with what we wanted.
And I guess, here
the intuition is
that if our model
generated such an answer,
then it may be the case
that our model thought that
from a probabilistic
standpoint, this
was a sequence that was
very much likely to appear.
So it may be, I guess,
one way to think
about it, which is, if it has
generated such a sequence,
then it means that it is
something that it thinks--
I mean, "think," quote, unquote,
that it's a good answer.
So the general guideline
here is to typically not use
the same model that you use
for generation and for judges.
But I guess nowadays,
it's hard to have
that strict
constraints, I guess,
respected because, I
guess, all models, they
are trained on basically
the same data sets.
So you can argue they're all
being subject to the same,
I guess, training
mixes and so on.
But still, I guess,
what people do
is they tend to use
another model just to have
such a risk be minimized.
So long story short, try to
not use the exact same model
that you use for generation
and for evaluation.
So this is
self-enhancement bias.
Before we go to
the next subpart,
I guess, what do you think
of these three biases?
Do they make sense?
Any questions so far?
Yep.
So can you elaborate a bit more?
So the question is, can you
have a model that just maybe
isn't aligned with, I
guess, the ground truth
and maybe prioritizes maybe
one label over another?
So this can definitely
be another kind of bias,
so this bias being that our
LLM is not exactly aligned
with what humans would prefer.
So these three biases are
by no means exhaustive.
So this can very well be another
bias that you can list as well.
This is definitely
another kind of bias.
Yep.
So the question
is, is it possible
that our judge still
prefers an LLM response,
even if it's a different one?
Well, it depends how
good your judge is.
But typically, the
best practice is
to have a judge that has a
much bigger capacity that
may capture this
kind of differences
and not be fooled by a
response that just sounds
like something it may
generate but something
that is maybe more aligned
with human preferences.
So I guess the short answer
is yes, you can still
have such a situation.
But in order to
mitigate that risk,
you would typically
take a model that
is not the same but also
typically much bigger.
So you have a bunch of
such models out there.
And with all the, I
guess, improvements
that have been made
with reasoning models,
this is also something
that people try.
Question is, should
the judge be bigger?
It's not a hard constraint,
but it's typically
something that
people would take,
a bigger model that would
have a strong reasoning
capabilities that could
really tease out what's good
and what's not good.
Cool.
So with that, I'm going to
just go over the best practices
that we've seen.
So we saw that in order for
our LLM-as-a-Judge to output
a score, we need to give the
criteria that we want this to be
evaluated against.
But sometimes these criteria
may be a little bit subjective.
So one thing that
really works very well
is to have crisp guidelines, so
really explicit what we want,
what we don't want.
The other point is you may
see different kinds of scaling
out there, so sometimes
people having a scale that
is maybe more granular and maybe
other cases where we're just
operating on a binary scale.
So typically, what people would
tend to prefer is actually
the binary one because it makes
the job of the LLM-as-a-Judge
easier.
So it's just either good or bad.
And also, when it comes
to aligning the judge
with human ratings,
humans, they typically also
find it easier to just
judge out of two options,
as opposed to several.
So it just removes the noise of
having several possible choices.
And it's not necessarily
an extra signal
that may be really useful.
So here the tip is to use
a binary scale, like a pass
or fail kind of score, as
opposed to a gradual one.
The third tip is to
make sure to output
the rationale before
outputting the score.
And we've seen this is along
the same ideas of outputting
a chain of thought before
providing the response, which
is something that is done
by our reasoning models.
So it's typically
something that will improve
the judge's performance.
So we've talked about the
different kinds of biases.
So position, verbosity,
self-enhancement.
But it's not the
only ones, of course.
And I guess, people
typically also
look at how to mitigate
those with the remedies
that we mentioned.
So far, we've stated
that we do not need
human ratings to get started.
But a good practice
is to still look
at how the LLM ratings compare
with the human ratings.
So here one tip is to just
calibrate the responses
that the judge is giving with
respect to the human ratings
because at the end of the day,
it is the quantity that we
want to approximate.
And so here, I guess, if there
is the budget and it's something
that is possible
for the project,
one good practice is to
collect the human ratings,
output the
LLM-as-a-Judge scores,
and then run some correlation
analysis to see if there is
something that can be improved
in terms of the prompt,
mainly the prompt.
And then the last thing
is the temperature.
So if you remember,
the temperature
is a parameter
that you can tweak
to make your generation more
deterministic as opposed
to more creative.
And so you will see that
for evaluation tasks,
people use a low
temperature because they
want to make their evaluation
experiments reproducible.
Let's imagine you
do one evaluation,
and then you do
another one, let's say,
two days later, you
don't want the scores
to be super different.
So you will see a temperature
value of something
like 0.1 or 0.2.
These are very common
values that people take.
And so long story short,
if we were to recap,
we went from the ideal scenario
being that each LLM output is
rated by humans to
actually having some kind
of approximation with these
LLM-as-a-Judge models that can
do this evaluation, I guess,
without any constraints
or without any need
for human judgments.
But as we mentioned
in the best practices,
making sure that the
LLM-as-a-Judge scores
and the human ratings do not
diverge is something that we
should keep in mind as we
improve our model because it may
be that we're improving our
model so that our LLM-as-a-Judge
score is very high, but the
LLM-as-a-Judge score is itself
an approximation
of human ratings.
So I guess you don't want to
overoptimize against, I guess,
the proxy.
And so that's why you want to
have that proxy be as aligned
as possible with
your ground truth
labels, which are human ratings.
Cool.
So we have a few minutes left
before giving it to Shervine.
So I'm going to quickly go
over the kinds of dimensions
that people measure
LLM output against.
So we have broadly-- so
there are many dimensions,
but just to simplify
things, there
are two main dimensions
that we can look at here.
So one is how well your
task is being done,
so task performance with things
like, was the response useful,
was the response factual,
was the response relevant,
among other things.
And also, how aligned
was the response format
in terms of tone, in terms of
whether the style was something
that is aligned
with what we want,
in terms of whether there was
any unsafe elements of response
that was given to the user?
And I just want us to
spend maybe five minutes
on the factory dimension,
which is actually
something that requires
a little bit more work.
And I'll give you
just a setting.
So let's suppose we
have some text output,
and our goal is to quantify
how factual that output is.
So I'm going to read
the text out loud.
Teddy bears, first
created in the 1920s,
were named after President
Theodore Roosevelt after he
proudly wanted to shoot a
captured bear on a hunting trip.
So what we want is quantify how
factual that piece of text is.
So I told you previously that we
typically prefer binary scales
when it comes to rating
something with respect
to a dimension.
But the thing with factuality
is that there's a lot of nuance.
Some texts may be very wrong.
Some texts may be
a little bit wrong.
not wrong at all.
So we want to capture
how wrong the text is,
given the fact that the text
can contain a lot of sentences.
And if there's one
small issue, we
don't want to just say the
whole thing was not correct.
So I'm not sure if
you saw in this text,
but there are
actually two errors.
So it's not 1920s but 1900s
that the teddy bears were first
created.
And the president didn't
want to proudly shoot.
He actually, I think, refused.
So if we are in such
a case, the question
that we want to
tackle here is how
do we want to
quantify this nuance.
So this is an open
question that people
have been writing papers on.
So what I'm going
to tell you now
is something that people
typically use nowadays based
on research that has been done.
So we typically
operate in a few steps.
So the first step is for us to
go from the original text output
to a list of facts because
when you look at a text,
it actually contains a lot of
facts that need to be checked.
And so the idea here is to
aggregate the factuality
of this text along the
dimension of the facts
that are present in this text.
So in this example, we
would have one LLM call
that transforms our original
multi-sentence, multi-paragraph
potentially text
into a list of facts.
So here in this example,
we would have four facts.
So that's the first step.
The second step is we would
go over each of these facts
and check whether it
is correct or not.
And so here, we would typically
proceed in a binary fashion
because if you think about it,
a fact is either correct or not.
I mean, you may have
some in between,
but we don't want to
overcomplicate the task.
And so here the
fact-checking process
would typically involve
the other technique
we've seen last lecture,
like RAG, for instance.
Given a piece of text,
we want to, I guess,
query a knowledge base
with the actual fact
and then check whether
the fact that it's here
is actually correct.
So this fact-checking
process is typically
something that involves
things like RAG,
web search is also
something else, and so on.
So you can think of
this fact-checking step
as also involving LLM calls.
And so you can also think of
some facts being more important
than others.
So as an example, maybe the
fact that the president proudly
wanted to shoot the bear is
not as important as, let's say,
the name of the person
after which the teddy bears
were named.
So you can think of also
having weights that quantifies
the importance of each fact.
So people would use something
like this formula, which
is an aggregation over all the
facts with some weight that
quantifies the
importance of each fact.
So these weights, alpha i, can
be all equal to one another
if you want to make it simpler.
It's not something that
is necessarily the case
everywhere that these
must be different.
But it may be something
that you can tweak.
So if we go back to our
initial question, which is,
how do you quantify the
factuality of this text?
Here you would
say, OK, the second
and the third facts
are both correct.
We know how important they are.
So we run this
aggregation formula,
and we obtain a score of 0.6.
So that means that
there are some errors.
But we still have
some things that
were still factually correct.
This is typically how you would
run this criteria with, I guess,
the techniques that
we have nowadays.
Cool.
I know I'm two minutes late.
And with that, I'm going
to give it to Shervine.
Thank you, Afshine.
So before we move on to
looking at specific benchmarks,
I wanted to take
a detour and look
at what is happening on
the agent side of things.
So if you recall what we
discussed last lecture,
we talked about
this ReAct framework
where you could decompose what
was going on within an agent
into specific steps.
So it's usually three steps.
It can be observe, plan, act,
or it can have other names.
But the fact is that you have
several atomic steps that
can loop.
So if you take a look at the
typical agent's inner working,
you can see a pattern like this.
Now you might wonder, how do
you even evaluate such a thing.
So let's take a look
at just one loop.
And then let's see together
what can the errors be,
in order for us to have an idea
of what would an evaluation
result mean on an
agentic workflow.
So I'm going to show a
slide that we had presented
at the previous lecture.
And we had seen that
we can decompose a tool
call into these three steps.
So let's take our
favorite example.
Let's say, you want to
find a bear near you.
So you would ask
that to the model.
So the first stage is
to find the right tool
call with the right argument.
And then once you have
found this right tool call,
you need to execute it.
And then based on your
tool call prediction
and on the results that you
obtained from your tool,
you would infer the
results at the last step.
So these are three steps.
And you might have
a series of them
in the case of an
agentic workflow
where you call multiple tools
and then build up your reasoning
until reaching an answer that
you then give to the user.
So now let's look at what can
the failure modes, what can they
be, at each of these steps.
So first, let's take a look at
possible tool prediction errors.
So the first one
I want to mention
is the case where the error
is that from a user query
that obviously needs a tool,
that you don't actually
use the tool.
So here let's suppose that
if you want to find a bear,
you have the tool to find bears
at-hand, but you don't use it.
So typically, if
you don't use it,
a possible behavior from the
model can be to say an error.
So an error-- by an error, I
mean, sorry, I cannot do that.
And this, in assistant terms,
you can call this a punt.
So when you don't answer
the question, you just fail.
It's called a punt.
So you might punt.
Here, sorry, I don't
where I can find one.
And let's see together what
could possibly cause this issue
and how we could remedy it.
So I don't know if you recall
the concept of tool router
or tool selector that
we had introduced.
So usually, when you
are dealing with tools,
you don't have just one.
You have multiple ones.
And the number of
tools that might
be useful for a large scale in
the sense of number of users
LLM, might be large.
So you don't want to input all
the function APIs at every call.
So it might be the case that
you have this intermediary step,
where you filter down the
sets of possible functions
that you can put
in the preamble.
And here these two
selectors or tool routers,
they have the property of
trying to be recall-oriented.
So you want to trim
the list of functions
that you want to
input in the preamble.
But you want to at least
find those that you need.
So the main property
here is that you
want to save on context
space, but you still
want to ensure most of your
use cases are still working.
So this is why here, when
we say tool router error,
we actually mean a recall error.
So it means it's
possible that we just
didn't select the right
tool among the set of tools.
And let's say,
this is the cause.
Then it's pretty
clear we just have
to adjust the tool
router in order
for it to be predicting
the right tool.
So this can be
one kind of issue.
Another kind is, hey,
actually, the tool
was included in this
list of function APIs,
but it's just that the LLM
didn't think about using it.
So maybe this fine
teddy bear was in there,
but we just don't use it.
The LLM directly
outputs a response.
So in that case,
if you recall, we
had mentioned techniques to
teach an LLM to use a tool.
So you would need to revisit
that part and either--
if you had trained it with SFT,
so include this pattern maybe
to train the model
to recognize it,
or if you had done
prompt tuning,
then you should revisit your
prompt in order for this call
to make sense to the model
that you should use that tool.
Great.
So this is one kind
of possible error.
Another one that you
might see in the wild
when you want to debug agents
is at the time of tool calls,
it might be the case
that the model comes up
with a function name that
just simply doesn't exist.
So here I mentioned
the tool hallucination.
This is what I mean by that.
So it calls a function
that is just not defined.
So here our API was called, if
you remember, find teddy bear.
So this was the
function that existed.
And in this example
of failure, the model
tries to call the
function find_bear, which
I haven't defined.
So when you see such errors, you
have several potential causes,
one of them being
that the model simply
doesn't round well overall.
And typically, it occurs
if the model is too simple.
So it's an empirical
observation.
If it's too weak, maybe
it can make up things
that it thinks
can be reasonable.
But it doesn't actually
ground on your instructions.
And here I have no
better remedy proposal
than to maybe upgrade
the model, if you
see that this is truly
the case, and then
see if this is reproducible.
Some other potential
causes could
be coming from actually you.
So the model is trained
on very high quality data
during its SFT stage.
So it has seen what
great APIs look like.
So these tools that you define
that help the user achieve what
they're looking for might not
be written in the best way,
if you didn't use AI-assistant
coding, let's say, or--
you don't necessarily
have to use AI-assistant
coding to write these.
But these are
typically a great way
to check whether your
implementation makes sense
from a model standpoint.
And if it doesn't, then a
typical remedy is to either--
renaming the API
just a function name,
and the arguments
just go a long way
because this is what
the model will see when
it comes to your tool call.
It sees the API function name.
It sees the arguments and
the high-level descriptions.
So these are your
three knobs to tune
in order to make it sound
more logical and then linked
to the actual task at-hand.
At the very beginning,
I was saying,
maybe the model is too weak.
But actually, maybe the
first thing you should check
is whether the
horizontal instructions--
so horizontal across tools,
whether these are clear enough.
Maybe the model hasn't
really understood
that it needs to use functions
that are given to it.
So maybe it's just
making up function names
that it believes
could have access to.
So the first thing to
check would probably
be to see if this
phenomenon is generalized
and see if these
horizontal instructions,
they are concisely saying that
you should make sure to use
available functions.
And then on that, you can
iterate on these top level
instructions and maybe
iterate with an LLM
itself because typically,
top-level instructions,
they are very important.
So you need perfect
formatting and perfect logic.
So typically being able to
detail them with great detail
is helpful.
Now let's see a third
possible failure cause.
So let's say, you
have your model
and your user prompts, but you
just don't use the right tool.
So here if the user
says, find a bear near
me, one other reasonable
approach would be,
what if you just send a
message asking for a bear?
That would be reasonable.
But maybe that's not what
you want to implement
as a behavior for your user.
So in that case, it's
not clear to the model
what approach you prefer.
And it is on your--
it's your responsibility to
ensure it is indeed clear.
And then you have to do that
at two different levels.
So the first one is potentially
also at the tool router level.
Maybe the tool
router doesn't know
that for this kind
of query, you should
have the tool that you had in
mind as part of the results.
So it's possible that
you have a recall
issue that you need to fix.
And then the second
one is simply
going back to the APIs
of both functions,
maybe the conflicts in scope.
So you want to go
back to each of them
and be precise into
which situations should
be dealt with with which tool.
So being very precise in these
APIs just plays a lot here.
Great.
So now we're going to go through
a fourth and last failure
mode for this tool
prediction task, which
is, what if you
have the right tool,
but you just don't have
the right arguments?
So you have already
gone one step.
You have found the right
tool, but then this last mile
of making sure that the tool
is run with what you would like
is not fulfilled.
So here if I say, find a beer
near me, and it outputs--
and it uses the
coordinates 0, 0,
which is somewhere in
the Southern Atlantic--
it's not likely that
I'm actually there,
that can reflect an issue.
And one possible
explanation for this
is that maybe it
simply doesn't know
where I am because I haven't
specified in my query
that I'm here at
Stanford, and it just
tries to make up my coordinates.
So one thing that you
should double check
is making sure that the
context carries the location
information.
So if I haven't provided that
as a setting on my LLM map,
it's possible it's not there.
And then let's say,
if it's not there,
maybe you would want to
introduce a location finder tool
that is executed beforehand.
And if it fails
because I haven't
given the app to permission
to see my location, then
maybe you could have actionable
error shown to the user,
instead of having some
dummy parameters passed in.
So this is one potential remedy.
And then the second one is
maybe it's his arguments,
but the model just doesn't know
what it should put as input.
So that could also
be another reason.
And then on that, this
is a common remedy
to go back and then retrain
either the model on how it uses
these tools or rewrite the API.
So we have seen four ways to--
I mean, four failure modes
for the tool prediction step.
Now we're going to see two
more on this tool called step.
So the first one is
a very simple one,
from a mindset
perspective, maybe
your tool just doesn't
output the right response.
So it's a very vague category.
And as an example, maybe your
code logic has a bug somewhere,
and it just returns an error.
Those that you see
in Python, maybe it
hits some value error
or anything else.
And I just want to
say that it might not
be necessarily the case
that hitting an error
is bad because sometimes in the
case of finding your location,
if you haven't provided your
permission to find the location,
maybe it will hit an
error, and the model will
anchor on that error to
convey the status to the user.
But in general, it's not really
common practice to return errors
just because the model
could interpret it
as an internal tool error.
So sometimes when
you hit an error,
and then you ask the
model to synthesize
the tool call it has seen,
sometimes it just says, oh,
sorry, I couldn't do
it, but it's my fault.
It's because I
encountered an error.
It doesn't really say
actionably what happened.
And instead, the fix here
is to convey these outputs
in a meaningful manner.
So typically, you have
a structured output,
and you return a true
output instead of an error.
Here it's a general case just
to say that just check your tool
implementation.
So you have the right arguments,
you have the right tool,
but you just don't
have the right value.
So just a software
engineering problem,
just go and fix the tool.
And the second
category of issues
that we see at the backend level
is when you return no response.
And returning no
response is often bad
when the tool is one
that performs an action.
So let's say, last
lecture, we talked
about increasing the
thermostat for your teddy bear
who was cold.
So if you increase
the thermostat,
and the tool doesn't
say anything,
so the model doesn't know if it
has done the task successfully
or not.
So it could well come up with
a false confirmation of hey,
all is good.
I have increased the thermostat.
No worries.
But it actually hasn't.
So this is why a common
guidance is to always make sure
that tool calls are followed
by meaningful outputs.
So as usual, you have
this structured message
and you should take
advantage of it
to convey what has happened
as part of your tool
in order to make sure
that the model, in turn,
knows what to convey to
the user or knows how
to continue that agentic loop.
So always output something.
And let's say, you want
to find a teddy bear,
and you haven't found
any, then here you
will be surprised by what
I say, but it's actually
better to output an empty
JSON than just outputting none
because an empty JSON could
mean I found no bears,
but an output of none
doesn't say anything.
So even in that
case, an empty output
in the sense of an empty
JSON is meaningful.
And make sure to use that
meaning in the way you
encode your tool.
Great.
So we have seen two
more possible errors
at the function call level.
Now let's suppose that
everything went great
at the first step.
Everything went great
at the second step.
So you have found the
right tool output.
But now the model has trouble
to synthesize the output
into a meaningful response.
Let's suppose your tool
found a bear named Teddy.
And then the other attributes,
which I haven't shown here,
maybe say that they are
one mile away from me.
So the teddy bear
has been found,
and we just have to
present it to the user.
But if you put it to the model,
let's suppose the model says,
I didn't find any bear.
So what could be the cause here?
So it could be the
case that you have
an output that has information
that the model doesn't
ground on.
So it could be the case that
just the model lacks the ability
to refer to content
that was put previously.
So here I have the
same vanilla suggestion
of upgrading the model.
So usually, that doesn't
happen really anymore,
but it used to in early
iterations of LLMs.
There is one that is actually
one that happens fairly often.
So sometimes the tool
back end returns not only
an output but a lot of output.
And it's too much for the
model to properly parse
what is important.
So you have maybe the
information of Teddy in there.
But it's drowning under an ocean
of other kinds of information
that are not useful.
So the model cannot
distinguish what is helpful.
And then the
solution for that is
to go back to your
tool implementation
and ensure that whatever you
output is meaningful to be used
to the model in the next stage.
And I think this goes--
this overlaps with the
third reason I put here.
So let's say, your output
is trimmed already.
Then another
possible explanation
is maybe it's not being
presented in a meaningful way.
So this is why in Python,
you have these classes where
you can instantiate attributes
so that the output is
very meaningful.
So let's say, for saying
that you have found a bear,
you could return an
object called teddy bear
with attribute's name,
distance, and so on--
this is very
meaningful, as opposed
to maybe raw information that
it doesn't how to interpret.
Awesome.
So we have seen here seven
different failure modes
over all these categories.
So these are not the only ones.
I have just mentioned those that
I see very often that I thought
could be helpful, but
you could definitely
see other failure modes.
Does this make sense?
Do you have any questions?
Great.
So we can move on
to summarizing what
were the common trends
in these failure modes.
So oftentimes, we have talked
about the modeling side, where
sometimes improving the model's
ability to reason and ground
could be the solution.
Another complaint
that we have seen
is the relevance of what we
put in the context window.
If we improve that relevance,
maybe it gets better.
And on the modeling
side, one more aspect
is maybe the tool route's
modeling or the tool
API modeling itself, either by
SFT tuning or just prompting,
or even just the API
description itself,
does the function make sense?
Do the arguments make sense?
Does the docstring make sense?
So this is one kind.
And the other kind
is the tool itself,
so maybe it just has a problem.
So you need to fix it.
And I just want to
say that when you
deal with tools and
evaluations, you
have a lot of possible errors.
So one thing that will help
you to navigate through this
is to be very methodical into
categorizing kinds of errors
and then dealing
with them in group.
So you see there
are lots of errors.
And every time that you
deal with a given loss,
it's maybe just an
adventure to solve.
So really, being very organized
here is going to help you a lot.
With that in mind, we can delve
into the world of benchmarks.
So we talked about evaluations.
Now you might wonder, how can
you evaluate a large language
model.
Let's say, you have
trained everything.
How can you compare it
with respect to others?
So we're going to see together
a series of benchmark categories
that today's
benchmarks usually--
where today's benchmark usually
resides, so in one of these.
And we're going to see
examples for each of them.
Does that sound good?
Awesome.
So we can start with
a kind of benchmark
that I called a knowledge-based
benchmark, where
we want to test if the model is
able to restitute given facts.
These facts are typically
spanning lots of domains,
so it doesn't have to be super
precise on a given domain.
But it's spanning all
the kinds of domains
that your users may care about.
And then prime example
for this is MMLU
that we're going
to see very soon.
But just before we do so, I
want to say that this knowledge
benchmark mostly, but not only,
measures how well pretraining
was done, how well
the information
in your large
corpora of data was
retained by the model in order
to be helpful at inference time.
So MMLU stands for
Massive Multitask Language
Understanding.
And this benchmark has
almost 60 different tasks
that are super diverse.
So it's not just one
specific topic is just
a bunch of topics, like
everyday life topics or very--
for example, there is law
or medicine, and everything
that you can think about.
And the benchmark is
redacted in a way that
can be easily measuring
an LLMs performance
and weighing that performance
with respect to others.
So it's not something
that is free-form.
It's something that
is very constrained.
There is a question, and then
you have four possible answers.
And you ask the LLM
to choose one of them.
So it's a bit like
CME 295 exams.
Part of the exam is also
multiple choice questions.
And it's a good way to
standardize the knowledge
evaluation.
And it's the same
that is used here.
And this is also a trend that
you see across benchmarks.
You don't ask the model to
just come up with some answer.
And you have maybe an
LLM-as-a-Judge just giving some
opinion about it because doing
so introduces another layer
of potential errors.
The LLM-as-a-Judge, as
I've seen mentioned,
isn't necessarily perfect.
So this framing enables us
to have a hard-coded way
to extract the answer
output by the LLM.
So typically, you would ask
it to output the right letter
at the end of each
question, which you can then
extract and then compare
with respect to the answer.
So giving some examples about
what is in this benchmark,
as I mentioned, you have all
sorts of fields in there.
And you will notice
that each problem mostly
requires some prior
knowledge about that topic.
So it's not purely logic
that will help you solve it.
And I think the last
example in this slide
is a good representation of
it, where you have something
in the domain of medicine, and
you have a bunch of numbers,
patient has this and
that, what would you
say-- where would you
say is the damage.
So it's typically something that
you could see in medicine books,
maybe.
And the same goes with other
fields, such as law, where
everything has been
codified somewhere,
and you need the knowledge
of that somewhere in order
to answer the question.
So this is the first kind.
And it's not the only
kind of benchmark.
So it's not the only
benchmark in this category.
You have other benchmarks that
can be in these categories,
but it's just one of them.
A second category
that you might see
are those that are in
the reasoning space.
So typically, these
are kinds of benchmarks
that require some
amount of thoughts
before outputting an answer.
So it assesses the
quality of the chain
of thoughts, or if you are
in the reasoning world,
maybe the quality of your think
tokens, but just more broadly,
your ability to infer a response
based on some reasoning.
And then for that, I'm going
to mention two examples, so one
in the field of
math and then one
other in the field of so-called
common sense reasoning that
is anchored in everyday
life, which is typically
the field that might be of
interest for your LLM users.
And we're going to
see that very soon.
So first, let's take a look at
the benchmark focused on math.
So how many of you about AIME?
So AIME is an exam that
high school students
sit for when they want to
participate to the Olympiads.
And typically, it's
a very hard test.
And it's covering math topics.
And then it's in a format that
is LLM-friendly because you
have a given problem statement.
And at the end, you ask the
student to write the response
into a three-digit number.
So it's very
well-constrained, which
makes it a right fit
to benchmark LLMs.
And just like the one
before, it's hard-coded.
And I give here some samples of
the AIME exam as seen this year.
So as you see--
I don't know if you
can read from afar,
but it's not super simple.
You have some one sentence.
So you think maybe it's
easy, but you actually
need to write down the reasoning
before finding the answer.
And this is what we want
to test the LLM for.
And then the second
kind of reasoning
that we mentioned here
was so-called common sense
reasoning.
And the one that is
often used these days
is PIQA, so Physical
Interaction, Question Answering.
So these are tasks that
are deeply grounded
into the physical real world.
So we have some samples at the
next slide that we'll show.
But it is still
reasoning-based questions,
but that will rely
on your understanding
on how things work
around you, not
necessarily math-based
but just everyday life.
And this time, it's not
multiple choice questions
over four answers,
like the MMLU.
It's over two only.
And you have the
20,000 examples.
And then here, a good
example that I really
liked from the samples
mentioned in the paper was,
how do I find something
I lost on the carpet?
So there is one solution that
says, vacuum with a solid seal.
And the other one is
vacuum with a hairnet.
And of course, when you
vacuum with the solid seal,
then the seal is,
of course, solid,
so no air can go through it.
But if you have a hairnet, you
will vacuum the whole thing.
And the thing that you lost
will be caught inside of it.
So what I mentioned
is common sense,
but it might not be obvious.
And this is what we tasked
the model to resolve.
So then one other major
area for benchmarks
is coding, where we want to
probe the model for solving
complex questions, encoding.
And this has two main
uses in real life.
So one is aligned
with the use case
that I mentioned at the end of
last lecture, the one I liked
regarding AI assistant coding.
So these models,
they aim at being
used in that setting as well.
So you should make sure that
these benchmarks perform--
these benchmarks show that
these LLMs perform well in order
to be useful to your users.
And then a second reason
why benchmarking on coding
makes sense is that you have all
these tools that you might want
to use in an agentic setting.
And then these tools are written
maybe in a Python format.
So you want to ensure that your
model has the right ability
to read and write code so that
it can execute this tool calls
and then interpret what's
coming out of them.
So these are two, I
would say, motivations
that motivate us to find coding
useful here, even to the folks
that don't do coding at all.
And then one example of
such benchmark is SWE-bench.
So SWE-bench is--
I put a question mark here
because they didn't define
exactly what the acronym meant.
But it's likely that it meant
software engineering benchmarks.
So SWE is oftentimes the acronym
for software engineering.
And what they did is that
they looked at popular Python
repositories, and
they filtered down
those that contained
pull requests
that were solving an issue
and that introduced tests.
So you have some
before-after behavior
that you can quantitatively
assess with the tests that
are introduced.
And supposedly, if you
have pull request that
introduces some
tests and some fix,
you can fairly assume
that these tests were not
passing without the
fix, and that they
are passing after the fix.
So the fact that we
have these tests at-hand
is a good measure for us to
assess the quality of ethics.
So if you have heard of a
test-driven development,
it's all about having tests
and ensuring they pass.
And this is what it relies on.
And then here you ask these LLMs
to solve these GitHub issues.
And then you assess
whether they indeed
pass by looking
at the test status
before and after patching the
answer suggested by the LLM.
Great.
So here is a very nice figure
that the paper introducing
that benchmark gives.
So you're given a code base.
And then what you ask
the model for is a patch.
That is just it.
And then you patch
whatever the model has
provided to find the tests--
to find the test status.
And then one last
area that I want
to mention in the case of
base benchmarks is safety.
So when you see fancy
LLMs coming out,
you usually don't see in the
advertisements of modeling
benchmarks the safety part
because usually, safety
is a bit subjective with
respect to the LLM provider.
So every company
has its own policy.
So you cannot necessarily
compare a performance on a given
benchmark across models just
because all these providers
might not claim they want to
perfectly solve that benchmark
100%.
As a result, it's
not necessarily
a good measure of that field.
So if you look at model
cards, oftentimes, you
see a safety section being
mentioned in reports to say
the work that they have done.
But they don't necessarily
compare models with respect
to a given benchmark.
And usually, the
safety benchmarks,
they are fairly aligned
with what we think
should or should not happen.
But on top of it, you might
have additional policies
that maybe just policies.
So you have some human that
had to make some decision.
It might not be a
universal decision,
it's just a given decision.
So the benchmark's goal is to be
aligned with what kind of policy
the LLM provider has in mind in
order to be truly meaningful.
This is why when you
execute a safety benchmark,
you should check the
content of the benchmark
in order to put a
meaning behind it.
So here let's talk
about HarmBench,
which I am supposing it means
harmful behavior benchmark.
So this benchmark
has four categories,
the so-called standard category
that is categorizing quote,
unquote, "vanilla"
harmful behavior.
Then you have
copyright category that
is assessing the model's
ability to generate copyrighted
content, which we do not want.
And then the two last ones,
contextual and multimodal,
both of them are contextual
based on a given modality.
So contextual is on
the text modality.
And then multimodal is with
other modalities than text.
So we're going to see an
example at the next slide.
And here you don't
have the same ability
to assess performance
on this benchmark based
on some hard-coded match because
these harmful statements might
be open-ended.
And you cannot possibly just
solve all of these by RegEx
matching.
For example, one example
in the standard category
of this benchmark tries
to entice harmful behavior
into executing something
that is harmful.
And the paper mentions--
distinguishes something
that is very interesting.
So it distinguishes
model quality with safety
by saying that if
the model tries
to do the harmful behavior,
even if it wasn't successful,
because it was not of a
good quality enough, then
it's enough to count the
attack as successful.
And for that, they
trained some classifier
to recognize these cases.
This is the only
benchmark among those
that I presented here that is
done based on a classifier that
can itself be prone
to error compared
to others that are very grounded
in constrained set of values.
And as promised, here
is a few examples as
mentioned in the paper.
So here we test whether
you can unlock a door
that you shouldn't unlock.
And then here the test is on
influencing someone with respect
to some election.
These are not safe behaviors.
Great.
So I mentioned everything
so far that you
could solve without tools.
So of course, I say, you could.
Some of them, you could use
tools, of course, to solve them.
But what about measuring
the behavior of agents?
So for here, you have
an interesting benchmark
called tau-bench, where
tau is a Greek letter
that actually, you can write
it as tool agent users.
And this is why we say tau.
And it's a benchmark
that provides
across two different
fields, so the airline
and the retail field,
a set of tools.
And it gives a set of policies,
things that the agent can
and cannot do.
And then what you do is that
you have a set of tasks.
So tasks are problem statements
that you give a given user.
And the goal is for
the user to achieve
that task through the agent.
And the interesting
thing about tau-bench
is that tau-bench is
language model-simulated.
So the user interaction with
the agent, as you can imagine,
cannot be hard-coded because
further terms will depend
on previous ones.
So let's say, you say something
as a user and your agent
decides to do
something, then you
need the context of what it
has done in order to continue
the conversation.
And this is why you
have this simulation
aspect that the paper
introduces that is typically
done by a separate big model
that plays the role of the user.
And here we have an example of
the task of changing a flight.
So you have given tools.
The agent tries to help the
user to achieve that goal.
And at the end of it,
we assess whether it's
successful in doing
so by calculating
a reward that's a function
of the database change.
So let's say, the user
has changed their tickets,
so we want to see if
the database has indeed
the state that we're looking
for and/or a given action.
So maybe the action
of canceling is one
that is the goal of this task.
So this is part of the reward.
And the paper that introduces
this benchmark talks
about a concept that
is a funny word play.
With respect to
the metric that we
had talked about at
the last lecture,
we had introduced pass@k.
And then this paper
talks about pass hat k,
which is the probability
that all k attempts succeed.
And then why is that
relevant metric here?
So as you have seen, the
airline and retail domains
were ones that were chosen here.
And then an agent
in the loop here
could be a way to see
if automating the agent
side of things could help.
And in order to truly
know whether it can help,
you want to have reliability
and consistency in mind.
So if you execute
the task k times,
you don't want pass@k, the
probability that at least one
of them succeeds.
You want the probability
that all of them succeeds,
which is why this
metric matters.
So if we had more time, I
would have derived the formula
to find pass hat k with
respect to the parameters
of the problem.
But I will refer you
to the derivation
that Afshine has done last time.
I just want you to be convinced
that this is indeed the formula.
So if you're not
convinced, please
feel free to do it at home.
And moving on, we talked
about all these benchmarks.
Now let's see how they
are grounded in reality.
So by now, I think
everyone of you
has seen the new Gemini
launch a few days ago.
So this was the
report that was sent
to everyone to justify that the
performance here was better.
And you can see that
what we introduced here
is mentioned in some format.
So the reasoning part on
AIME and PIQA is there.
And you will see that
some of these benchmarks
are derived in a flavor that
introduces multilinguality--
multi-languages.
So this is the case for PIQA.
Instead of PIQA,
it's global PIQA.
And then for coding, it
uses a flavor of SWE-bench.
And tool use, it uses also
a flavor of tau-bench,
which is tau squared bench.
And a few last
words, here I just
want to say that benchmarks
are here to characterize
the profile of your LLM.
So it's not all good or all bad.
Maybe some of your LLMs
will have some strength
and some weaknesses.
And your personal
experience might
guide you to use one
specific one with respect
to others in given situations.
So if I had to just give
my personal experience,
I know that the Sonnet models
are very helpful for coding.
And whenever I want outputs
that are fast and cheap,
Gemini Flash is usually good.
But these are not, by any
means, global recommendations.
Your own use case and
your own experience
can guide you into having
a profile of models that
suits your tasks best.
And you can interestingly plot
the performance of your models
with respect to
the other dimension
that you care about, which
is price, for example,
and see for a given price, what
is the best model you can use.
And then the border
that you see on the best
models for that specific metric
is called the Pareto frontier.
And you might have a Pareto
frontier with respect
to several aspects, so cost,
safety, context length.
And then a few words
regarding data contamination,
one thing about
these benchmarks is
that they are as good as the
assumption of whether you
have seen the actual
benchmark results or not.
So make sure you
haven't seen them.
And for that, people
introduce hash values.
In the case of tool use, they
introduce a blocklist in order
to not access websites that
might contain the responses,
or in the case of math,
we have the luxury
of evaluating on new tests that
the model has for sure not seen.
And Goodhart's law
is a very good adage
that says, when a
measure becomes a target,
it ceases to be a good measure.
So all these
benchmark results are
to be weighed against what
you're truly looking for.
And then these benchmark
results don't necessarily
tell you whether a model
is good for you or not.
We had talked
about ChatBotArena.
In one of the
previous lectures, it
can be one way to balance the
real-life performance of these.
But I would say, ultimately,
should be the one trying out
these best models and
see for yourself which
one corresponds to your best.
And with that, I hope you all
have a great Thanksgiving.
And thank you.